that's their idea of uh that's the whole
thing about what privilege is is that
you
you you people don't like to have
their pleasure interrupted and if you
really want your pleasure interrupted
tune in to don lemon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah it's another glorious monday
in the city that never sleeps uh who are
we kidding
there's bums passed out all over the
place but the rest of us have to stay up
all night and guard our stuff from
looters
it's true according to the nypd data
hundreds of suspects nabbed for looting
and rioting after the george floyd
protests
have all had their charges erased yep
the charges were wiped out
like cat after having one too many
vodkas in first class
yes you're a queen
you're in
the queens of charges must be great news
to business owners who can look forward
to more repeat customers from their
growing base
of faithful looters it's sort of like a
steal one get 100
free sale it's a lesson in incentives
lack of punishment
doesn't just remove a disincentive to
crime it becomes an
incentive to do more of it as if the
flat screen you stole wasn't enough
according to an nbc new york
investigation the bronx are borough
ravaged by
fires and mass looting some more than 60
percent of the charges dropped
and in manhattan where looters freely
assaulted soho and midtown
over 200 of those arrested had their
cases dropped
but according to the media pointing out
that problem makes you the problem
take new york city mayor candidate
andrew yang who in the last mayoral
debate tried to explain what every
citizen in this
shaken town understands the fact is
mentally ill
homeless men are changing the character
of our neighborhoods
uh a woman my wife ellen is friends with
in her mom group in hell's kitchen was
punched in the face by a mentally ill
man this is happening in new york city
and we're not talking enough about it
families are leaving as a result yes
mentally ill people have rights but you
know who else have rights we do
the people and families of the city we
have the right to walk the street and
not fear for our safety because a
mentally ill
person is going to lash out at us amen
he makes sense he speaks soberly and
rationally
the exact qualifications democrats hate
in a mayor
consider new york times columnist
michelle goldberg who upon hearing yang
wrote this quote every other candidate
spoke of homelessness as a disaster for
the homeless
yang discussed it as a quality of life
problem for everyone else
and because of that she couldn't vote
for yang so she's stupid or deliberately
misleading it's hard to tell she's
got a track record for both but our
assumption is that if you express
concern about the legitimate safety
concerns of the city you
live in you lack compassion for the
homeless it's as if normal folks can't
hold two ideas in their heads
that we can't aid the homeless and the
citizens who deal with them on the
streets
maybe it's just the writer who can't
hold two ideas in her head and her
stupidity prevents others from speaking
out
knowing she'll label them fascists for
wanting to protect their loved ones
i didn't think weaponizing compassion
was possible
but that's how michael bolton got me to
buy all those albums
but maybe goldberg's idiocy is designed
to make her readers feel
smarter by the time i was done reading
her column i felt like i could have
solved a rubik's cube with my toes
so the next time you wonder why the
street seems like a war zone
blame your lack of compassion for
expecting better
this as joe biden's white house asked
american citizens
to report on friends and family who have
potentially radicalized beliefs
no they didn't say report on someone who
did something
but report on someone who believes
something and you know what that means
a different political view will now be
viewed as radical because that's how
democrats operate now
and what a better way to unify the
country than having families snitching
on each other
real crime is okay thought crime
severely punished
so while actual criminality is now a
protected class the white house will
direct funds and agents to an internal
threat
that is yet to present itself as a
cohesive thing
like who are these massive
well-organized domestic terrorists
you mean the looters and the gangs a lot
of them
sure don't look like white supremacists
so why
this new war on terror well it's a
distraction
and an expansion of power and this
expansion involves targeting people
whose views run counter to the white
house intimidating opposition into
silence and driving them underground
that can't be good
i guess allowing left-wing mobs to
attack you isn't the only way to shut
you up
meanwhile violent crime is the silliest
of concerns say the media
it's just pornography for midwesterners
says popping fresh it's like almost
pornographic if you're living in the
middle of the country and you're reading
about san francisco all the time and
like the worst and
by the way there's problems in cities
there's problems everywhere but if you
read about them constantly you're going
to blow him out of proportion
of course why is it the legacy media
only cares about
blowing the crime out of proportion
rather than the crime itself
in journalism all sides deserve to be
heard that's why he covers the explosion
of crime from the perspective
what's the big deal right brian if
you're in kansas
who cares if a brat gets shot in times
square this is the mentality that led to
the phrase peaceful protest
sure minneapolis was on fire but
somewhere a cornfield was just fine
bottom line you can't cover the news if
it makes far-left policies look bad
stelter is arguing for less coverage of
a widespread
explosion in crime now isn't that weird
coming from a journalist
to be any less concerned about crime
you'd have to be holding a sign that
says defund the police
so hearing about people being beaten
robbed and murdered is
almost like pornography i guess where
cnn anchors live
they're more cut off than dan don lemon
on new year's eve
it's where crime is porn and watch from
behind the locked front gate protecting
your
highly secure home i got news for
stelter
if you consider an asian elderly woman
being beaten by a repeat offender in
broad daylight to be pornographic
twinkies aren't your only problem
[Laughter]
maybe i'd see a sex therapist and not
the one tubin
is using either
let's welcome tonight's guests
she's so bright kat had to wear
sunscreen tonight
washington examiner commentary writer
kaylee mcgee white
he knows more about defense than the 85
bears former defense department chief of
staff
ash patel
[Applause]
they'll only protest a bakery if their
eclairs suck
outspoken editor chief chadwick moore
and she's like a goldfish she's shiny
and won't remember
any of this fox news contributor cat tip
all right chadwick welcome back to the
show thank you sir you like me
live in new york and are good-looking
is andrew yang right about the homeless
situation here
yeah he is right but you know i mean the
democrats have acknowledged they have to
address the homelessness and the
vagrancy in the city basically falling
apart
here's what i hate about andrew yang and
actually what i find so depressing
is he's sort of this continuation he's
this annoying millennial continuation of
what
bloomberg started in this idea that new
york is a luxury brand you know that
like
that uh you know it's not a place where
people have roots that people
live right that people like have
families and people and
and a unique culture of its own it's
just a place for the world to come
yes and andrew yang's not a new yorker
right you know he just plopped down here
and
uh it's like there was um there was a
journalist who who sort of
said the new political paradigm is more
of a class of people called the
somewheres and some
and the anywheres right and the the
somewheres were more the sort of brexit
trump people who had this sort of roots
and these anywheres were just
flitting around globalists yes and
andrew yang is so much represents
that transformation of new york that
this is a really interesting point
because
it explains a really diabolical
consequence of this is that the people
that
come when it gets bad can leave right
but the elderly
and the poor that live in the city and
have been there whether it is in the
bronx or in harlem
they don't have that luxury so all of
all of us like you know
well-off uh beautiful people i mention
myself as one of them
and when when the going gets rough i can
lead i can leave to go to florida
i can go to nashville but all these all
these
little yeah the asian families in
chinatown that are out there getting
their butts kicked by crazy people
they're stuck there yeah that's a really
good point i wish i came up with it
tomorrow i will repeat it on the five
and act like it was my idea kaylee
welcome to the show
thank you this is your first time here
yes good luck
[Laughter]
why where do you see this going if the
democrats
offer no solutions this can only get
worse because they're in charge
well it's not only going to get worse
but you're going to continue to see
people leave the city in droves like you
said the people
who can afford to will because no one
wants to own a business in a city where
shoplifting is so common that a guy in
san francisco
can walk into a walgreens with his bike
and start shoveling goods into his trash
bag and then just
ride out on his bike in front of a
security guard and several other
customers
no one wants to live in a city where an
elderly asian woman
is going to get beat in the face and
people around her aren't going to do
anything about it
it no one wants to live in a city that
is unlivable and so good people
who are paying the taxes in new york
city they're going to end up leaving to
states like florida and to other places
where a lot of people during covet have
left
yeah you know the thing is though if
you're a democrat you can go well you
know i don't really own a walgreens and
i'm not an elderly asian lady
so i'm safe right i live in the upper
west side i got a gated building not a
gated building a secured building with a
lot of security so
so i'm safe cash to the young lady's
point kaylie's point
about businesses where are the insurance
companies like in this
it seems to me that you don't you
they're the they're
the dog that's not barking in all of
this
why is that because because do they tell
these businesses
hey just like let the goods go we'll
cover it i don't know what's going on
here i mean i prepare for a lot of
topics for your show but insurance
wasn't like that
so i'm just going to wing this by the
way i want to i want to congratulate you
for winning the pga tournament i like
the jacket that you got
you can sign it later yes okay answer
what are your thoughts on the state of
crime in america that is so generic that
even you can answer i can't do it
yes i used to be a public defender and a
federal prosecutor
so both sides of the coin you like that
yes yeah
[Laughter]
so it's really fundamental right if you
arrest people for being criminals
you can't let them out on bond right
right and then you can't
have no crime when everyone you arrest
is committing more crime
after they already committed crime and
then when they commit their third crime
you give them a light sentence and say
here is money from an insurance company
go to the bar right do it again yes
there you go this doesn't work
yeah but you know what because democrats
know
like it used to be cat that the
democrats and
i leave out libertarians in this just
for for the sake of simplicity
they were the yin and yang democrats and
republicans the republicans were like
the
they were the the to be sexist the
father
the law and order and then the democrats
were compassion they were the mom and
they came together
and they formed a loving bond that ruled
the gov ruled the united states but it's
not that way anymore
because the democrats don't want to be
seen as aligning with the republicans
over law and order so now you have chaos
right and if you don't even have to
answer that we're going to break of
course you are the first
you're the first person to ever leave
libertarians out so
uh absolutely and if you watch that
segment you watch steltzer you don't
have to argue with him
other than just to walk around new york
right you can see with your eyes or with
photos videos that he's completely wrong
i mean new york is so expensive
and i'm paying all these taxes and given
the amount of taxes that i'm paying
i would like to you know have the luxury
of walking around at night
and feeling safe the and like the
pornographic aspect the amount of
homeless people i've seen having sex
on the street the number's not zero it's
not two
it's not even three last week saw
a vagrant being shall we say serviced
in the bushes outside my apartment and
nobody wants to do anything about it
you're talking about kyle yeah we have
we had a thing yeah i apologize for that
yeah well you know put kyle up in a
hotel room because i can't take it
anymore
but you know what the thing is though
what you're talking about is you have a
limit of finance that other people like
people like stelter and and michelle
they are willing to fork out the money
because they're protected and in the
long term this is going to end up
with private security for everybody that
can afford it and it's just not
nothing you're never ever going to find
the best solution when
you're not accepting reality yeah the
reality you can
plainly see it by just looking at new
york yeah all right
and this is going to get worse for
everybody so i know that people get like
we talk about new york too much
but it was once the best city in the
world and now it's absolutely
yeah so there you go hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else